everyone where'd CES 2016 I'm with
Travis first from Razer and we were to
check out two new products today the
first one being the upgrade to the Blade
laptop line that's been a fan favorite
for a long time but now you guys have a
thinner model it's also pretty
affordable can you tell me what
differentiates this you know just beyond
the form factor from the previous
versions of the blade so we just
introduced the ultimate ultrabook it's a
twelve and a half inch notebook with up
to a 4k resolution panel that display is
absolutely stunning it supports a
hundred percent of the Adobe RGB color
spectrum so great for photo editing and
other work as well but it's very thin
and lightweight since it is an ultrabook
it's a CNC aluminum chassis there was
only two point seven five pounds so not
only is it lightweight but it's also
durable okay and I see you guys also
have the RGB keyboard support in there
as well so what is the battery life with
this because obviously when you you know
you slim something down you do sacrifice
some features so I'm curious if I'm
playing a game like which panel is this
is this like a 1080p or is this the 4k
one we have a quad HD and a 4k panel so
no 1080p got just only high resolution
and they're all touch based panels as
well um the battery life is up to eight
hours so pretty pretty good battery life
and so it's eight hours where I'm
assuming just like desktop use and web
browsing what about for gaming if I was
playing you know say fallout 4 you know
how many hours could I get on the go
with this with the I guess the lowest
spec machine
yeah well the idea what the Ultrabook is
you take it with you when you're on the
go it's thin and light but when you want
to do some hardcore gaming and you want
to get serious that's when you'd plug in
the razor core external desktop graphics
amplifier ok so describe that to me
because what it looks like is you just
got a desktop GPU hooked up to a power
supply that's feeding back into this how
does that actually work so the notebook
itself has Thunderbolt 3 which allows
for transfer speeds of up to 40 gigs per
second via that Thunderbolt connection
you can connect it up to Razer core in
the graphics amplifier you would install
your own preferred GPU whether it be AMD
or Nvidia and that's what really gives
you that additional full gaming
experience it's also got ports on the
back including additional USB and
Ethernet so you can really transform the
Ultrabook into that full desktop gaming
compete
and so is there a limit to what GPU can
you know put in there like can you throw
a Titan in there if you wanted to so it
has a 500 watt power supply so and it's
got some additional cooling as well
it supports full-length dual wide pci
express graphics cards from both AMD and
NVIDIA okay and so I'm assuming you guys
are selling this just as is without the
GPU and so how much does this go for on
its own so the notebook is not starting
at $9.99 and that's for a quad HD screen
and a core i7 processor with the razor
core is going to come out later on this
year in the first half we have not
announced pricing and availability yet
but it'll be we're pretty excited for it
to come out
so coming very soon all right I think
you Travis very much for showing us it's
exciting new gear looking forward to
testing it out down the road for more PC
coverage stay tuned to GameXplain at CES
2016
you